Deep in the mountains of western Norway lies Trollstigen Road.
Trollstigen translates directly to "troll's ladder".
Trollstigen is a visual feast.
I have never seen a place that was so...
One, it makes your stomach drop.
It is a straight cliff drop down to the valley.
This road is the hardest and the highest bike climb in the entire world.
12.2 kilometers of this ride is at a grueling seven percent incline.
The view from the top is just...
You can't even put into words how breathtaking...
...and just vast this view is off into the distance.
Norway is hands-down the most extreme  place I've ever been.
The landscape is just...
Look at this!
There were certain points where I hit 60 kilometers per hour.
I cannot highly recommend enough going to this place.
It is breathtaking in every aspect of the word.
Literally, it will take your breath away especially if you're biking up it...
...or you're biking down, Trollstigen Road is a must...
...if you're going to northwestern Norway.
You have to see this place.